And I'm merely saying it's something to look
into that there were campaigns, awareness
campaigns about the riotous insurrection planned
for January 6th that were targeted to folks
who, for example, listed in there likes U.S.
Marines, U.S. Navy, Air Force, or that listed
in current or former occupations, military.
It certainly can be done as far as the technology
is concerned.
So then it just becomes a question as to whether
there was the volition and the awareness to
do it.
We don't yet know all the answers, but the
early numbers certainly are concerning.
If nothing else, you may or may not know that
a week from tomorrow, February 9th, is the
start of the second impeachment trial of Donald
Trump.
Remember, impeachment happens in the House.
I'm still getting emails from saying David
Trump hasn't been impeached yet.
No, no, no.
He's been impeached.
He was impeached once and the Senate acquitted
him.
He's now been impeached a second time by the
House.
And we don't yet know how the Senate will
vote, although we kind of do.
The Senate is in all likelihood going to vote
to acquit Donald Trump.
Again, that trial starts a week from tomorrow,
February 9th.
And very bad news for Donald Trump.
I guess, depending on your perspective, all
of Donald Trump's possible lawyers have quit.
South Carolina lawyer Butch Bowers and four
other attorneys who had signed on to represent
Donald Trump in the second impeachment trial
all abruptly quit over the weekend.
This is just days before the trial is going
to start.
Trump, of course, is going to be on trial
for having been impeached for his role in
inciting the attack on the U.S. Capitol on
January 6th.
Unbelievable that it's already been almost
a month since.
That feels like it was yesterday.
And Donald Trump's office announced late last
night that two new lawyers are going to be
taking over the defense.
The reason we are being told that Trump's
up until hours ago legal team has quit is
that Trump reportedly wanted those lawyers
during Trump's defense in the Senate to also
make the case that Trump actually won the
election.
Now, it's really important to understand what
this means.
One defense of Trump would be Trump didn't
incite a riot, he just didn't inside to right
that he had no responsibility whatsoever.
When I hear that Trump wants his lawyers to
argue that he actually won the election, it
occurs to me that Donald Trump wants to do
what's called an affirmative defense, meaning
he isn't going to deny what he's accused of,
but he's going to argue it was justified.
So when you're accused of murder, for example,
one defense would be, I didn't do it.
I didn't kill anybody.
An affirmative defense would be I killed them.
But it was self-defense.
You're acknowledging that the literal act
took place, but you're arguing it's not a
it's not it's not illegal.
You shouldn't be punished for it because it
was a justified self-defense action.
If you say to me, Trump wants his lawyers
to argue he won the election, to me, it's
sounding like Trump wants the argument to
be made that Trump did incited, although I'm
sure they would use other words.
But it was justified because Trump did win
and they were trying to get back for Trump,
what was rightfully his.
It seems insane to me to make that argument.
And it seems Donald Trump's legal team, what
was his legal team up until last night, agrees
with that and they are not willing to participate
in it.
Trump's attorneys initially planned to focus
the strategy on whether the impeachment is
constitutional, given that Donald Trump is
gone and what the definition is of incitement
and making the case that Donald Trump didn't
really incite anything.
And of course, when Donald Trump says claim
I won the election, that changes significantly.
Donald Trump, according to people close to
him, was telling his lawyers, let's litigate
the voter fraud allegations, let's litigate
the 2020 race.
Let's litigate all the stuff that was litigated
for really a period of two months starting
right after the November 2012 election, and
make it a defense of my actions rather than
an argument about constitutionality or that
that kind of defense.
This seems to have been extremely triggering
to Donald Trump's lawyers.
Trump spokesman Jason Miller says that the
split was mutual between Trump and the attorneys.
I don't believe that for two reasons.
Jason Miller lies about everything.
And Trump doesn't tend to have mutual splits
with people.
Either they resign or he angrily fires them.
And for that reason, it doesn't seem plausible
at all.
Now, I love I'm imagining this dream idea
that Trump ultimately can't get anybody to
stay with them through the trial and that
he ends up representing himself.
And it becomes sort of like a cartoonish legal
drama.
I don't think it's going to happen.
But can you imagine if Trump showed up and
tried to defend himself, represent himself?
The reason I don't think it will happen isn't
because Trump doesn't think he could do a
good job.
Trump is exactly the type of narcissist that
would think he can do a good job defending
himself.
I don't think it'll happen because reports
are that Trump is very confident that he is
not going to be convicted and he's probably
right about that.
And thus he doesn't really think it's worth
putting that much effort into this.
He's going to just find some lawyers to help
him.
He's not getting convicted anyway.
So why why worry about it too too much?
On the other hand, we know Trump often doesn't
pay his lawyers, so it seems he'd be well
intentioned or well situated to hire the best
lawyers that he can and then simply stiff
them like he's tried to do to most of his
lawyers, including reportedly Rudy Giuliani.
I don't know the sad truth, the sort of final
thought about this.
Trump could show up, represent himself, admit
guilt repeatedly.
The Senate Republican cult still wouldn't
convict Donald Trump.
That's how horrifying the status quo of Republicans
in the Senate now is.
So in a sense, Trump can do whatever the hell
he wants and he's going to get away with an
acquittal, will be covering it.
We will also have more coverage about the
lead up, including about Donald Trump's lawyers
on The David Pakman Show Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show and follow me on Instagram at
David Pakman, The David Pakman Show at David
Pakman dot com.